this video is sponsored by raycon
earbuds and will begin right after a
short message
hey guys it's me maskington abandoned
i'm wearing this high quality homemade
mask because it's spooky month
but you know what's really spooky is not
having quality wireless earbuds to jam
out with well i'm here to tell you that
this is the fix right here no this isn't
a treasure chest it's a charging case
that holds up to four
charges without needing to be plugged in
but it does contain treasure
inside the raycon
everyday e25 earbuds alone last up to
six hours without needing a charge with
seamless bluetooth pairing all new
re-engineered audio quality featuring
more bass than ever
and a snug noise isolating fit so it
doesn't fall out of your ears
they even come in all sorts of different
colors so even you can look as cool as
me
[Music]
hold your applause and there are only
about half the cost of other premium
wireless earbuds out there on the market
but what's better is if you go to
www.buyracon.commnb
or click the link in the description
below you can get 15
off your order so be sure to check out
these bad boys today
and now on to the video
[Music]
what a time to be a zelda fan am i right
for old fans and new fans alike ever
since the release of the widely beloved
and
hugely successful title breath of the
wild we can say with full confidence
that we
are indeed living in a new age for the
legend of zelda
also it released over three and a half
years ago
why am i so old as we march through this
much too eventful year and it nears its
end
we have a couple more things in gaming
to be excited about and i'm not just
talking about the game awards or
cyberpunk 2077 although i am
very excited about that i'm talking
about the prequel to breath of the wild
that's going to release the day after
cyberpunk no joke
uh between these two games i'm not sure
i'm going to remember how to sleep
or eat but what this video is about is
the fact that the anticipated release of
the prequel to the biggest
zelda game to date could possibly change
my mind about how i feel about breath of
the wild for those of you who aren't
super veterans of my channel and haven't
seen this video right here
by the way seriously this is not an ad
for that video don't don't
watch it i mean that it's super old and
even more cringy than my current videos
if you can believe that
but anyway i cover my opinions about
breath of the wild in that video and to
say the least it's not quite as rosy as
one would think coming from a channel
that's been built on breath of the wild
videos so far but before i rub you too
far the wrong way
let me briefly summarize my viewpoints
from that video
i can still remember the immense amount
of electric excitement like i had never
felt before when i brought home my
brand new nintendo switch with the brand
new zelda game ready to go
i had taken like four days off of work
just to hold myself up in my room and do
nothing but play
zelda and those first several hours
playing the game were some of the
greatest moments i can remember from
my lifetime of playing video games it's
no secret that the game holds a certain
magic in the exploration of its wide and
expansive world
that even led to nintendo claiming the
game of the year award for its release
in 2017
so as i was playing it i definitely felt
that magic and that sense of
awe the never before seen massive scope
of just good old adventures to be had
but after i played the game for oh maybe
10 hours or so
that's when i did myself and the game a
disservice
actually a lot of fans did the same
thing even though it didn't really have
to be done
i compared breath of the wild with my
favorite zelda titles from the past when
it came to exploration
clearly breath of the wild stood way
upon its own tier since
no other zelda title or really other
video game in general had its world map
size with a breakthrough innovation
gaming mechanic called
climbing any surface that gave the game
a scary amount of verticality
the voice acting from main characters
was also a surprising but
very welcome feature that was brand new
to breath of the wild but
every time i discovered a new memory
from the past that would play a little
mini movie
and help fill in some of the backstory
to the game i felt this
longing in my zelda fanatic heart
growing slowly each time i felt that the
world and events and characters that
were alive in those memories from so
long ago
were more interesting than the world i
was able to explore instead
in fact and i forget if i said this in
my previous review video or not but i
actually began to tell my friends and
others playing the game that i just
wished we were able to go
play through those memories instead of
just watch cutscenes that were each a
minute or two long don't get me wrong
breath of the wild's hyrule is vast with
varied climates but it's barren at least
as opposed to the world alluded to in
the cutscenes
that's when i began to really compare
breath of the wild head to head
to other zelda games in ways other than
just exploration
and that's when i began to ask questions
like where the real dungeons were or why
i couldn't swim
underwater or why there were so many
trial of strength shrines or why i
inexplicably felt like i shouldn't use
any of my powerful weapons like ever and
these comparisons which turned into
questions
soon turned into disappointments and
disappointments
led to complaints because i kept
remembering the enemies or dungeons or
characters or music from past zelda
games
it's almost like i removed my ability to
see breath of the wild for what it was
really trying to be
and it's not like breath of the wild
didn't have all of those and some pretty
good music too
it was just the first of its kind a
zelda game leaning heavily on experience
and less on storytelling not that it
didn't have both of course
the one thing i ended up saying at the
end of it all was that i
felt breath of the wild would be
perfected if that one thing happened
if we were able to play through the
events of 100 years ago
to me that would have solved the
captivating storytelling from previous
zelda games that i
felt it was missing when the dlc's were
announced i actually thought that that
was what was going to happen
since we were delving into some
never-before-seen stories with the
champions back in the day
but again it was just a few cutscenes
and a nice wallpaper that every other
zelda fan used for like a year
then three years passed and breath of
the wild remained one of my favorite
games
but not my favorite zelda by the way if
you know what my favorite zelda game is
comment it below and the first few
people that get it right
i'll heart their comments to let you
know it was correct but anyway fast
forward all the way to about a month ago
when a trailer dropped out of
absolutely nowhere a new hyrule warriors
game was announced but not just a
regular old hyrule warriors game
a breath of the wild game too a holy
matrimony of sorts between the two
franchises that promised to bring
exactly what i felt that breath of the
wild was missing all along
the backstory the playable backstory
that would create
actual memories and actual relationships
with the characters that actually matter
to the story
because let's face it breath of the wild
kinda drops the champion's descendants
off the face of the earth after you use
them to get to the real champions
even though they're just ghosts at this
point now my relationship with hyrule
warriors is also
not a rosy one i know i'm such a
depressing person to listen to
apparently
and my reasons for that viewpoint are
actually kind of covered in my last
video about my expectations for age of
calamity so i won't go into them too
much here
but in summary i just really don't like
hack and slash games hey now
zelda games are normally hack and puzzle
there's a big difference thank you very
much
but from the gameplay footage that i was
able to tune into on my recent vacation
this game looks so much more like breath
of the wild than it does hyrule warriors
it's going to have even more voice
acting a baby guardian
more cinematics an adorable baby
guardian
the same map but with different
landmarks more characters some of which
are old but young
or new entirely and most importantly it
will explain what exactly happened
100 years ago first hand it's also going
to have
a baby guard this game if done correctly
could change the way i feel about breath
of the wild as a whole
we've never seen a direct prequel to a
zelda game featuring the same world and
characters before
and i feel that because of this they
should be looped together as two parts
of a whole since they're so closely
connected if this game delivers then the
breath of the wilds might be able to
claim the spot at the top of my zelda
list that hasn't budged for decades
it might change my mind and it might
change yours
too but i suppose we will see either way
in just a little over a month actually
in the meantime though thank you so much
for staying with me throughout this
video essay of mine kind of trying to
generate some hype for the game
and for those of you who left likes or
even subscribed to the channel
thank you so much i look forward to
discussing the game further with you
when it releases
since you'll be sticking around also
huge thanks to my supporters you all
stuck with me even after my radio
silence when i was on vacation
which was amazing by the way thank you
for asking if you're interested in
supporting the channel and helping the
next video come to life
please feel free to check out that join
button below or the links in the
description also below
there are some pretty cool benefits and
discounts on merch that come with each
tier so
huge thanks in advance for checking them
out also also down there are the links
to my social media pages like twitter
and insta so hey
why not come on over and connect with me
there as well that way i never go radio
silent
that's all i've got for this one so do
me a favor and try to have a wonderful
rest of your day
maybe catch another video of mine you
haven't seen yet i'll see you next time
but till then this
is mass nintendo bandit signing out
peace
[Music]
you